Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Alice:那是不是很不礼貌
Alice: Isn't that very rude?
Shure: 我觉得直接开吃也没问题吧
Shure: I think just starting to eat is fine, right?
Alice:那我等这么久岂不白等了
Alice: Then wouldn't my waiting be in vain?
Jake:确实不白等
Jake: It’s definitely not in vain.
Jake:不白等啊
Jake: Not in vain, really.
Lucia: 不少凳子
Lucia: Not missing chairs.
Lucia: 我把那个凳子搬过来就不少了
Lucia: If I move that chair over, it won't be missing.
Jake:我来搬
Jake: I'll move it.
Lucia: 那你帮我开我的那个啥
Lucia: Then help me open my, uh, thing.
Jake:好你给我加油谢谢你
Jake: Okay, cheer me on, thank you.
Jake:哎你的L3为什么没带
Jake: Hey, why didn't you bring your L3?
Jake:你怎么还没有带呢
Jake: Why haven't you brought it yet?
Tasha: 他没帮我连啊
Tasha: He didn't connect it for me.
Jake:哦那找到高奥特了
Jake: Oh, then found Gao Ao Te.
Jake:哦你先上Google试一试
Jake: Oh, try Google first.
Jake:对上Google看看这个梯子他对不对
Jake: Yeah, check on Google to see if this ladder works.
Jake:我们可以
Jake: We can...
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm...
Jake:这还能再往上打吗
Jake: Can this go up any further?
Shure: 我说他那个那个电影里面用的这把琴
Shure: I'm talking about the guitar used in that movie.
Shure: 我忘了那个名叫啥了
Shure: I forgot the name of it.
Shure: 你应该知道我说的是哪个
Shure: You should know which one I'm talking about.
其他人：啊我知道了
Others: Ah, I got it.
Shure: OK
Shure: OK.
Jake:打不了
Jake: It won't work.
Lucia: 好像不行啊
Lucia: Seems like it doesn't work.
Jake:上不了Google
Jake: Can't get on Google.
Jake:你你这个Google能上吗能
Jake: Can you get on Google with this?
Alice:能
Alice: Yes.
Jake:错了错了错了
Jake: Wrong, wrong, wrong.
Jake:跪了跪了
Jake: We're done.
Jake:唉哎
Jake: Oh...
Jake:啊这个你在
Jake: Ah, you are...
Lucia: 啊现在能上去了
Lucia: Ah, now it works.
Jake:所以你要选一下
Jake: So you need to select one.
Lucia: 然后呢
Lucia: Then what?
Jake:然后
Jake: Then...
Jake:上Google能上的话就可以去二维啊
Jake: If you can get on Google, then you can go to the second dimension.
Jake:输这个密码啊
Jake: Enter this password.
Lucia: 雨轩发的这个
Lucia: The one Yuxuan sent?
Jake:对
Jake: Yes.
Jake:你的L3
Jake: Your L3.
Shure: 是啊
Shure: Yeah.
Katrina: 拿着你的手机别挡道
Katrina: Hold your phone, don't block the way.
Alice:吃饭也是要记录的是吗
Alice: Do we need to record meals too?
Jake:嗯好咱就今天就记录一下
Jake: Hmm, okay, let's record today.
Tasha: 好
Tasha: Okay.
Jake:吃盒饭以前没怎么记
Jake: We haven't really recorded meals before.
Katrina: 操不完的心
Katrina: Endless worries.
Katrina: 哎呦
Katrina: Oh dear.
Shure: 快去吧工人
Shure: Go quickly, worker.
Shure: 这家没你会散的
Shure: This place would fall apart without you.
Lucia: 你现在是两人一盒吗
Lucia: Are you sharing one box per two people now?
Tasha: 对女生是
Tasha: Yes, for girls.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Jake:啊哦
Jake: Uh oh
Tasha: 我觉得吃不完
Tasha: I don't think I can finish it
Alice:一个人一盒的话您觉着呢
Alice: If each person gets a box, what do you think?
Tasha: 我也觉得我负义
Tasha: I think it's too much for me
Lucia:  可以但咱俩坐的有点远
Lucia: It's fine, but we're sitting a bit far
Tasha: 啊坐的有点远
Tasha: Yeah, we're sitting a bit far
Jake:那要不然
Jake: How about...
Lucia: 要不咱俩换一个
Lucia: How about we switch seats?
Jake:好嘞
Jake: Alright
Lucia: 你那有点晒我不想去
Lucia: But it's a bit sunny over there, I don't want to
Jake:哈哈哈那要不我就在这吧
Jake: Hahaha, then I'll just stay here
Tasha: 那我拿这个吧
Tasha: Then I'll take this one
Lucia: 没事没事我用那个就可以
Lucia: It's fine, I'll use that one
Jake:没事少吃少一点点
Lucia: 谢谢
Lucia: Thanks
Lucia: 为什么如此郑重哈哈
Alice:今天二十几号啊
Alice: What day is it today?
Tasha:  你想吃啥啊
Tasha: What do you want to eat?
Lucia:  我都行你吃啥我请
Lucia: Anything is fine, I'll treat you
Tasha: 你想吃啥
Tasha: What do you want to eat?
Jake:我想吃那两个炒蛋
Jake: I want those two scrambled eggs
Tasha: 好那你们两个
Tasha: Okay, then you two...
Tasha: 那你们两顿
Tasha: Then you two...
Lucia: 什么
Lucia: What?
Katrina: 没有碗了
Katrina: There's no bowls left
Katrina: 只有碟子
Katrina: Only plates
Katrina: 把碟子吃吧
Katrina: Use the plates to eat
Katrina: 当盖浇饭
Katrina: Like a rice bowl
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh
Katrina: 就是
Katrina: Exactly
Katrina: 不是没有碗了吗
Katrina: Aren't there no bowls left?
Alice:哎这不好多筷
Alice: Hey, there are plenty of chopsticks here
Alice:给你个筷子 你有筷子吗
Alice: Here, have some chopsticks. Do you have chopsticks?
Jake:怎么回事
Lucia: 这饮料有人喝吗
Lucia: Is anyone drinking this?
Katrina: 昨天是到了你可以直接对
Katrina: It was from yesterday, you can drink it
Alice:昨天是谁的
Alice: Whose was it yesterday?
Lucia: 那我对嘴喝
Lucia: Then I'll drink directly from it
Lucia: 还有人要喝吗
Lucia: Does anyone else want some?
Jake:如果海那我拿个杯子呢
Jake: If there's some left, can I get a cup?
Jake:我哎整一点你们要吗
Jake: Hey, I'll get some more. Do you guys want any?
Jake:我多拿几个杯子来吧
Jake: I'll grab a few more cups.
Katrina: 杯子都没洗
Katrina: The cups aren't even washed.
Jake:我拿12345678
Jake: I'll take 12345678.
Jake:那行吧
Jake: Alright then.
Katrina: 这有碟子要吗
Alice:木须肉吧
Alice: How about some Moo Shu Pork?
Jake:对这是木须肉
Jake: Yes, this is Moo Shu Pork.
Jake:哈哈哈这杯子是不用了吧
Jake: Hahaha, we don't need this cup, right?
Alice:哈哈
Alice: Haha.
Alice:哈
Alice: Ha.
Katrina: call back一下
Katrina: Call back later.
Jake:这杯子是没用了吧
Jake: This cup is not needed, right?
Alice:不用了哈哈哈
Alice: No need, hahaha.
Jake:好的那就用这个吧
Jake: Alright, then let's use this one.
Lucia: 我觉得8个人吃哇哈哈哈
Lucia: I think 8 people can eat, hahaha.
Jake:对O
Jake: Yes, O.
Lucia: 用来喝水的吗OK
Lucia: For drinking water? OK.
Lucia: 8个人吃两盘炒鸡蛋还
Lucia: 8 people eating two plates of scrambled eggs...
Alice:哦我不用了
Alice: Oh, I don't need it.
Alice:水水给他吃
Alice: Give the water to him.
Tasha: 这怎么不算纸杯
Tasha: How is this not counted as a paper cup?
Lucia: 两个人吃两盘炒鸡蛋多少
Lucia: Two people eating two plates of scrambled eggs, how much...
Shure: 这什么呀
Shure: What is this?
Jake:纸纸杯啊
Jake: Paper, paper cup.
Alice:喝饮料的
Alice: For drinking beverages.
Shure: 不是
Shure: No.
Shure: 杨老板太幽默了吧
Shure: Jake, you're too funny.
Jake:这怎么了
Jake: What's wrong?
Jake:不能喝吗
Jake: Can't drink from it?
Jake:不能喝
Jake: Can't drink?
Lucia: 我想知道AI会怎么解释这个行为啊
Lucia: I wonder how AI would explain this behavior.
Jake:就是这是一个杯子吗
Jake: It's just a cup, right?
Katrina: 没用完的继续用
Katrina: Keep using the ones not finished.
Jake:对
Jake: Yes.
Shure: 那我们后期打标注怎么打
Shure: How should we label this in post-production?
Shure: 到底是这个是cup还是那个纸杯是cup
Shure: Is this a cup or is the paper cup a cup?
Jake:这不都是Cup吗
Jake: Aren't they all cups?
Shure: 这这咖啡真的能装水吗
Shure: Can this coffee really hold water?
Jake:为啥不能实验一下
Jake: Why not test it out?
Lucia: 实验一下
Lucia: Let's experiment
Lucia: 我们要有科学精神
Lucia: We need to have a scientific spirit
Shure: 来杨老板你拿这提一杯哈哈哈
Shure: Come on, Jake, you take this and lift a cup, haha
Jake:哎那我先带头
Jake: Alright, I'll take the lead
Katrina: 干了干哈哈哈
Katrina: Bottoms up, bottoms up, haha
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Lucia: 看起来好容易洒啊
Lucia: It looks like it's easy to spill
Jake:给给给您给您斟上
Jake: Here, here, let me pour for you
Tasha: 叫这么多
Tasha: So many
Shure: 哈
Shure: Haha
Jake:给您斟上
Jake: Let me pour for you
Lucia: 那我自己来
Lucia: I'll do it myself
Lucia: 哈哈哈谢谢谢谢
Lucia: Hahaha, thank you, thank you
Lucia: 辛苦你了
Lucia: Thanks for the effort
Alice:给你一块
Alice: Here's a piece for you
Lucia: 倒这么小一个杯子不洒
Lucia: Pouring into such a small cup without spilling
Alice:你吃热吧
Alice: Do you want to eat it hot?
Jake:哈哈你们还修硕也喝吗
Jake: Haha, are you guys and Shure also drinking?
Jake:那来点吧
Jake: Then let's have some
Jake:整点
Jake: Just a bit
Shure: 我先不来我先不来
Shure: I'll pass for now, I'll pass for now
Jake:哈哈哈都不来了
Jake: Hahaha, nobody wants it
Jake:要吗
Jake: Do you want it?
Jake:别的都不要好嘞
Jake: No one else wants it, alright then
Jake:干杯
Jake: Cheers
Jake:干完了好干杯
Jake: Finished it, alright, cheers
Jake:他喝啥了喝多了
Jake: What did he drink? He drank too much
Lucia: 干杯cheers
Lucia: Cheers, cheers
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Shure: G
Lucia: 毫不意外
Lucia: No surprise
Lucia:  这要不能放这个
Lucia: You shouldn't put this
Jake:可以
Jake: It’s fine
Jake:可以这太妙了
Jake: It’s fine, this is great
Jake:这些设施妙啊
Jake: These facilities are great
Lucia: 妙啊
Lucia: Great
Jake:确实很妙
Jake: Really great
Lucia: 因为这个盘稍微有点小有点软
Lucia: Because this plate is a bit small and a bit soft
Shure: 有点湿是吗
Shure: A bit wet, right?
Jake:嗯
Jake: Yeah
Shure: 土豆怎么了
Shure: What's up with the potatoes?
Jake:给筷子
Jake: Give me the chopsticks.
其他人：我感觉有点生啊
Others: I think it's a bit raw.
Lucia: 这我怎么没看出是什么
Lucia: I can't tell what this is.
Shure: 拿下北欧南了吗
Shure: Did we take down Northern Europe?
Lucia: 辣死
Lucia: So spicy.
Katrina: 你就别提了行吗
Katrina: Can you not mention it, please?
Katrina: 我再也不喝酒
Katrina: I'm never drinking again.
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Shure: 放心只会有0次和无数次
Shure: Don't worry, it'll either be never or countless times.
Jake:哦你这凳子大了点
Jake: Oh, your chair is a bit big.
Lucia: 哦原来如此
Lucia: Oh, I see.
Lucia: 我说之前搬凳子算了
Lucia: I was thinking about moving the chair earlier.
Jake:好吧
Jake: Alright.
Jake:还能坚持一天
Jake: I can hold on for another day.
Jake:挺强的
Jake: Pretty strong.
Shure: 确实因为因为会很难受
Shure: For sure, because it can be really uncomfortable.
Jake:第二天下午就直接喝
Jake: The next afternoon, just drink directly.
Shure: 是真的闻到那个味我就想吐
Shure: Seriously, just smelling it makes me want to throw up.
Alice:我咋了
Alice: What's up with me?
Tasha: 分散一点
Tasha: Spread out a bit.
Alice:做什么春秋大梦
Alice: What kind of daydreaming are you doing?
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Jake:木须肉是没有肉吗
Jake: Is there no meat in this moo shu pork?
Jake:是有肉肉丝是吗
Jake: There should be shredded meat, right?
Alice:那不是肉吗
Alice: Isn't that meat?
Lucia: 是不是很有迷惑性
Lucia: Isn't it confusing?
Jake:哼哼肉丝很少
Jake: Hmph, there's very little shredded meat.
Jake:我来问问木须肉为什么叫木须肉
Jake: I'll ask why it's called moo shu pork.
Lucia: 好问题我也想知道嗯
Lucia: Good question, I want to know too, yeah.
Alice:那是木耳吗
Alice: Is that fungus?
Shure: 不是
Shure: No.
Jake:那是啥呀
Jake: Then what is it?
Shure: 他是苜蓿是苜蓿
Shure: It's alfalfa, it's alfalfa.
Jake:木须肉为
Jake: Moo shu pork...
Jake:啥是木须肉啊
Jake: Why is it called moo shu pork?
Shure: 木须肉为什么叫木须肉
Shure: Why is moo shu pork called moo shu pork?
Jake:看你俩GPT时间长吧哼
Jake: Seems like you two have been on GPT for too long, huh.
Shure: 肯定我的嫌快
Shure: Definitely, mine is faster.
Jake:我是上海GPT
Jake: I'm the Shanghai GPT.
Jake:你这是哪
Jake: Where are you?
Shure: 我这个
Shure: I'm here.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahaha
Tasha: 你输了哈哈哈哈
Tasha: You lost, hahaha
Katrina: 嗯是有点
Katrina: Yeah, a bit.
Katrina: 那边福建广东话
Katrina: That's Fujian and Cantonese over there.
Katrina: 那是上海话他的
Katrina: That's Shanghainese.
Katrina: 完了
Katrina: Done.
Jake:刚问完木须肉
Jake: Just asked about Mu Shu Pork.
Katrina: 这样也能撩
Katrina: You can flirt like that too.
Katrina: 竹子学习中哈哈哈
Katrina: Bamboo is studying, hahaha
Katrina: 独自学习
Katrina: Studying alone.
Jake:就是情话是吧暧昧期
Jake: So it's sweet talk, right? The flirting phase.
Katrina: 暧昧期说的话
Katrina: Things you say during the flirting phase.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha
Shure: 他他妈是你教的吧
Shure: Did he learn this from you?
Shure: 怎么说半道开始说英文了呢
Shure: Why did he start speaking English halfway through?
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
其他人：没有啊
Others: No, he didn't.
Shure: 对不起
Shure: Sorry.
Jake:你让GPT少喝点哈哈哈
Jake: You should let GPT drink less, hahaha
Shure: 别提了算了
Shure: Don't mention it, forget it.
Shure: 不揭你老底了
Shure: I won't expose you.
Lucia: sorry sorry sorry sorry sorry sorry
Lucia: Sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry.
Alice:哇刚看见
Alice: Wow, just saw it.
Jake:哦哦
Jake: Oh, oh.
Alice:我以为我今天不用洗衣服了呢
Alice: I thought I didn't need to do laundry today.
Tasha: 快去洗
Tasha: Go wash it quickly.
Jake:他俩也要洗了
Jake: They need to wash it too.
Alice:居然了
Alice: Really?
Jake:救命他俩也要洗了
Jake: Help! They need to wash it too.
Alice:算了不是明显打游戏
Alice: Forget it, it's obviously for gaming.
Jake:我这其实也要洗
Jake: I actually need to wash it too.
Jake:但是我已经弃疗了
Jake: But I've already given up.
Jake:就是虽然你不洗
Jake: Even though you don't wash...
Alice:我每天都在洗
Alice: I wash every day.
Jake:但是你理论上是要洗嗯是
Jake: But theoretically you should wash, yeah.
Alice:每天都在洗
Alice: Every day.
Alice:因为我每次吃饭都会弄衣服上
Alice: Because I always get food on my clothes when I eat.
Alice:然后还带的都是钱衣服
Alice: And I always carry money in my clothes.
Lucia: 对而且吃饭弄衣服上得赶快洗
Lucia: Yeah, and if you get food on your clothes, you need to wash it quickly.
Lucia: 如果不赶快洗洗不掉了
Lucia: If you don't wash it right away, it won't come off.
Lucia: 现在洗就洗掉了现在洗就洗掉了
Lucia: If you wash it now, it'll come off. If you wash it now, it'll come off.
Tasha: 现在洗就洗掉了
Tasha: If you wash it now, it'll come off.
Lucia: 洗过了
Lucia: It's washed.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Hmm.
Jake:有点厉害
Jake: That's impressive.
Alice:你吃吧给
Alice: Here, you eat.
Tasha: 雪冰珠醒了
Tasha: Xue Bingzhu woke up.
Jake:珍珠醒了
Jake: The pearl woke up.
Tasha: 嗯我跟他聊了一会
Tasha: Yeah, I chatted with him for a bit.
Jake:哦嗯
Jake: Oh, okay.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Yeah.
Jake:这么有意思
Jake: That's interesting.
Tasha: 很有意思
Tasha: Very interesting.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Jake:这是啥时候掉的
Jake: When did this fall off?
Jake:我都没发现
Jake: I didn't even notice.
Jake:我觉得我这裤子不能要了
Jake: I think I can't keep these pants anymore.
Jake:谢斌竹发烧了
Jake: Xie Binzhu has a fever.
Tasha: 哈喽哈喽哈喽
Tasha: Hello, hello, hello.
Tasha: 了
Tasha: Yeah.
Jake:心不如发烧
Jake: Better to have a fever than a broken heart.
Jake:还能来吗
Jake: Can he still come?
Shure: 你让他们别来
Shure: You should tell them not to come.
Shure: 我们害怕
Shure: We're scared.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Jake:确实那别来了
Jake: Yeah, seriously, better not come.
Lucia: 他是感冒了吗
Lucia: Does he have a cold?
Lucia: 他昨天就有点不舒服
Lucia: He wasn't feeling well yesterday.
Alice:没人看到
Alice: Nobody noticed.
Shure: 是啊昨天他就发烧
Shure: Yeah, he had a fever yesterday.
Shure: 昨天晚上他拿那个温针量了一下
Shure: He took his temperature last night.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Shure: 30 将近38度吧
Shure: It was almost 38 degrees.
Tasha: 37度6 嗯
Tasha: 37.6 degrees, yeah.
Shure: 嗯差不多不到38度
Shure: Yeah, almost 38 degrees.
Shure: 大家回去就是自测一下
Shure: Everyone should go home and check their temperatures.
Katrina: 总感觉我脑子也热热的
Katrina: I feel like my head is hot too.
Tasha: 是不是我第一天发烧说传给他了
Tasha: Did I pass my fever to him on the first day?
Tasha: 然后我好了他发烧
Tasha: And then I got better, but he got a fever.
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha
Jake:好吧
Jake: Alright.
Katrina: 没喝多少
Katrina: Didn't drink much.
Katrina: 就一杯那个
Katrina: Just one glass of that.
Katrina: 后来调第二杯都没喝完哎
Katrina: Later, I didn't even finish the second glass.
Katrina: 是不是龙舌兰度数比较高啊
Katrina: Isn't tequila quite strong?
Shure: 不是你可能倒多了
Shure: No, you might've just poured too much.
Alice:我也不会被吃了
Alice: I won't be eaten either.
Alice:这又掉了
Alice: Oh, it fell again.
Alice:我应该买个吃饭用的围裙
Alice: I should buy an apron for eating.
Shure: 我在吃中午饭
Shure: I'm having lunch.
Shure: 你可以给我讲一个
Shure: Can you tell me a...
Shure: 关于中午饭的笑话吗
Shure: ...joke about lunch?
Katrina: 玩一天是吧
Katrina: Play all day, right?
Shure: 是的
Shure: Yes.
Shure: 完了他卡住了
Shure: Oh no, it's stuck.
Jake:有有道理
Jake: Makes sense.
Lucia: 哇这个凳子太难移动
Lucia: Wow, this chair is so hard to move.
Jake:哎呀哈哈哈哈
Jake: Oh my gosh, hahaha.
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Shure: 哈
Shure: Ha.
Jake:吃点那个
Jake: Have some of that.
Jake:流水席走一波
Jake: Let's go for a banquet.
Tasha: 这个是你干的吗
Tasha: Did you do this?
Jake:不是我干的
Jake: I didn't do it.
Tasha: 干完了吗
Tasha: Is it done?
Jake:不是我干的
Jake: I didn't do it.
Jake:总查查干的
Jake: Jack did it.
Jake:这不是我干的
Jake: This wasn't me.
Jake:哦这个
Jake: Oh, this...
Jake:这个他屋子里边的这小彩旗串一半
Jake: This, the little flags in his room, half done.
Jake:这是什么
Jake: What is this?
Jake:这也是
Jake: This too.
Jake:我靠
Jake: Oh my.
Jake:悬崖勒马
Jake: Stop right there!
Jake:耶
Jake: Yeah!
Alice:我
Alice: I...
Alice:的天哪
Alice: Oh my gosh.
Jake:哎呦
Jake: Ouch.
Shure: 我记得
Shure: I remember
Shure: 他这个会用一个非常磁性的声音
Shure: He would use a very magnetic voice
Shure: 跟你念什么
Shure: to recite something to you
Jake:他拒绝了也是吧
Jake: He refused, right?
Shure: 我想听一点成人的内容
Shure: I want to hear some adult content
Jake:真简单
Jake: So simple
Jake:哎呀
Jake: Oh my
Shure: 完了是我服务不到位了
Shure: Oh no, I didn't serve well
Shure: 老板来给
Shure: Boss, here
Jake:那没晚了晚了
Jake: No, it's too late, too late
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha
Jake:哈
Jake: Ha
Lucia: 行
Lucia: Okay
Lucia: 这次离老离老板最近也是两盘炒鸡蛋
Lucia: This time, the closest to the boss were two plates of scrambled eggs
Jake:好
Jake: Alright
Lucia: 当我的领导就必须得吃炒鸡蛋
Lucia: To be my leader, you must eat scrambled eggs
Jake:谢谢
Jake: Thank you
Shure: 去拿杯可乐
Shure: Go get a Coke
Lucia: 以后在我简单里加一点
Lucia: Add a little in my simplicity next time
Lucia:  擅长迫使领导吃炒鸡蛋
Lucia: Good at forcing the leader to eat scrambled eggs
Jake:可以
Jake: Sure
Tasha: 这个好像不是很强迫的样子
Tasha: This doesn't seem very forced
Jake:谢谢
Jake: Thank you
Lucia: 不用谢
Lucia: No need to thank me
Lucia: 这个杯子倒的时候真的有一种喜感
Lucia: There's a real sense of joy when pouring this cup
Tasha: 天才
Tasha: Genius
Katrina: 像古代的那种
Katrina: Like those ancient ones
Jake:嗯对小酒盏哦
Jake: Yeah, like those small wine cups
Tasha: 哦
Tasha: Oh
Alice:明天续上
Alice: Continue tomorrow
Tasha: 就剩这么点了你就不能给老板倒掉啊
Tasha: There's so little left, can't you just pour it out for the boss?
Alice:你数一下位数不得了吗 11位啊
Alice: Can't you just count the digits? It's 11 digits
Jake:干了
Jake: Done
Alice:这不正常的吗
Alice: Isn't this normal?
Alice:干嘛被人夺射了
Alice: Why did someone snatch it away?
Alice:身上有脏东西
Alice: There's something dirty on it
其他人：不是我身上用这个
Others: Not me, use this
其他人：他不是一般都是取件码吗
Others: Doesn't he usually use the pickup code?
其他人：取件码不都8位吗
Others: Aren't pickup codes usually 8 digits?
Alice:也有6位啊
Alice: There are 6 digits too
Alice:这我一般都不用
Alice: I usually don't use this.
Alice:我直接就是那个复制那个订单号
Alice: I just copy the order number directly.
Alice:然后找一下他那个取件码就行了
Alice: Then I find the pickup code, and that's it.
Jake:咱还有快递吗
Jake: Do we have any more packages?
Jake:今也可以有
Jake: We might have some today.
Alice:没有
Alice: No.
Jake:啊哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Shure: 谁藏了这种好东西
Shure: Who hid this good stuff?
Shure: 居然不交汞
Shure: And didn't hand it over?
Shure: 是不是你藏的
Shure: Is it you who hid it?
Lucia: 这是维生素片吗
Lucia: Are these vitamin tablets?
Alice:健胃消食片
Alice: Digestive tablets.
Katrina: 我想要吃健胃消食片
Katrina: I want to eat digestive tablets.
Lucia: 这能吃饱吗
Lucia: Can these fill you up?
Jake:哈哈哈这几片看来不行
Jake: Hahaha, it doesn't seem like these few tablets can.
Lucia: 但我小时候真的好奇过这个问题哦
Lucia: But when I was a kid, I was really curious about this.
Jake:呵呵
Lucia: 就是它本身是占一定的体积的
Lucia: I mean, they do take up some space.
Lucia: 所以吃下去它更饱
Lucia: So eating them makes you feel fuller.
Lucia: 为什么会健胃消食呢
Lucia: Why do they help with digestion?
Shure: 啥时候吃都行
Shure: You can eat them anytime.
Shure: 你想起来吃就行
Shure: Whenever you remember, just eat them.
Tasha: 那你要饭前吃
Tasha: You should eat them before meals.
Tasha: 不
Tasha: No.
Tasha: 就是做好这顿要大吃一顿的准备了
Tasha: I mean, you should be prepared to have a big meal.
Tasha: 是吗
Tasha: Right?
Jake:嗯
Jake: Yeah.
Jake:那要吃少了是不是就会饿
Jake: So if you eat less, you'll feel hungry?
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈那要没吃够预期的话
Lucia: Hahaha, if you don't eat as much as you planned...
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah.
Lucia: 不就白吃了吗
Lucia: Isn't it a waste?
Jake:就没吃就比方说中午没有吃到
Jake: Like if you don't eat lunch...
Jake:然后中午就会就会饿晚上就会多吃
Jake: You'll be hungry and eat more at dinner.
Lucia: 大晚上你不知道自己会吃那么多
Lucia: You don't know how much you'll eat at night.
Jake:对是的
Jake: Yes, exactly.
Shure: 我没有我们宿舍
Shure: I don't have it in our dorm.
Jake:哈哈哈是这么回事
Jake: Hahaha, that's how it is.
Shure: 那个碎的
Shure: The broken one.
Tasha: 这有这有
Tasha: It's here, it's here.
Shure: 嗯你问问那个王少他们宿舍
Shure: Hmm, ask that guy Wang Shao from their dorm.
Lucia: 别说我CUP都要烧了
Lucia: Don't say that, my CPU is about to burn out.
Jake:啥呀
Jake: What?
Tasha: 谁谁又发烧了
Tasha: Who's got a fever again?
Shure: 他怎么打电话不说拜拜就挂电话呀
Shure: Why does he hang up the phone without saying bye?
Shure: 他好没礼貌啊真的
Shure: He's so rude, seriously.
Jake:啥呀
Jake: What?
Tasha: 他好像也发烧了不知道
Tasha: I think he also has a fever, not sure.
Jake:不
Jake: No.
Tasha: 不知道呀哦
Tasha: I don't know, oh.
Tasha: 呀
Tasha: Yeah.
Shure: 谢边竹嘛
Shure: Thanks to Bian Zhu.
Jake:就谢民族吧
Jake: Just thank the nation.
Alice:昨天晚上回去了
Alice: He went back last night.
Shure: 他昨天晚上回去了
Shure: He went back last night.
Tasha: 他还烧着呢
Tasha: He's still got a fever.
Shure: 他烧着呢
Shure: He's still got a fever.
Shure: 他烧起来了现在
Shure: His fever is back now.
Tasha: 还烧起来了
Tasha: The fever came back.
Tasha: 别来了
Tasha: Don't come over.
Lucia: 燃起来了嗯
Lucia: It's burning again, yeah.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Jake:别来了刚先说说你烧起来吧
Jake: Don't come over, just say you're burning up first.
Lucia: 刚修硕说你烧起来吧
Lucia: Shure just said you're burning up.
Lucia: 刚才这个
Lucia: Just now...
Shure: 你不应该想到骚起来
Shure: You shouldn't think about getting wild.
Shure: 哈哈哈你怎么这么正经
Shure: Haha, why are you so serious?
Jake:Lucia:
Jake: Lucia:
Lucia: 下次一定
Lucia: Next time for sure.
Lucia: 你现在给我建议了一个语库联系
Lucia: Now you've given me a language resource.
Shure: 啊对
Shure: Ah, right.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Shure: 就是这个
Shure: That's it.
Shure: 被打断了之后那个线上就死立不掉了
Shure: After being interrupted, the line just dropped.
Shure: 你知道吧
Shure: You know?
Jake:哈
Jake: Huh.
Shure: 大兴
Shure: Daxing.
Alice:那个这个
Alice: That, this...
Lucia: 啊谢谢谢谢
Lucia: Ah, thank you, thank you.
Alice:你们那叫啥
Alice: What do you guys call it?
Lucia: 莲花白
Lucia: Cabbage.
Shure: 哦还行
Shure: Oh, that's alright.
Lucia: 你们叫啥
Lucia: What do you call it?
Tasha: 圆白菜圆白菜
Tasha: Round cabbage, round cabbage.
Shure: 你坐19号线很快
Shure: You can take Line 19, it's quick.
Alice:圆白菜
Alice: Round cabbage.
Shure: 一个小时就能到
Shure: You'll get there in an hour.
Alice:洋白菜圆白菜
Alice: Cabbage, round cabbage.
Shure: 嗯 6点出门是完全来得及的
Shure: Yeah, if you leave at 6, you'll definitely make it.
Katrina: 白菜
Katrina: Cabbage.
Alice:白菜
Alice: Cabbage.
Jake:包菜包菜
Jake: Bok choy, bok choy.
Jake:包菜包菜是
Jake: Bok choy, bok choy is...
Lucia:  对圆白菜也
Lucia: Yeah, also round cabbage.
Lucia: 我们那边也这么叫
Lucia: We call it that too.
Lucia: 但是一般可能做两个吧
Lucia: But usually, we might make two dishes with it.
Shure: 6点半必须出门
Shure: You have to leave by 6:30.
Shure: 才一小时7分钟
Shure: It only takes an hour and 7 minutes.
Shure: 还得去个安检什么的
Shure: Plus you need to go through security and all that.
Shure: 只能怪
Shure: Just blame it on...
Katrina: 我靠这音乐姐真的想去
Katrina: Wow, this music really makes me want to go.
其他人：11点之后
Others: After 11 o'clock.
其他人：我还得从T2跑到T1去找我朋友去
Others: I still need to run from T2 to T1 to find my friend.
Shure: 他先到北京
Shure: He's arriving in Beijing first.
Shure: 哦
Shure: Oh.
Alice:莲花白这个名字很明显比圆白菜好吃
Alice: The name "lotus cabbage" obviously sounds tastier than "round cabbage."
Shure: 我记得你飞到浦东还是虹桥
Shure: I remember you flew to Pudong or Hongqiao.
Jake:就这个东西叫
Jake: This thing is called...
Jake:嗯
Jake: Yeah.
Shure: 虹桥虹桥
Shure: Hongqiao, Hongqiao.
Lucia: 叫啥就包菜
Lucia: What's it called? Just bok choy.
Jake:很粗暴
Jake: It's pretty rough.
Lucia: 我还以为这个名字是叠词包包菜
Lucia: I thought the name was a repeating word, like "bok bok choy."
Jake:包包菜
Jake: Bok bok choy.
Alice:地瓜红薯
Alice: Sweet potato, yam.
Lucia: 地瓜
Lucia: Sweet potato.
Lucia: 在我们那红薯就叫地瓜然后土豆叫洋芋
Lucia: Where I'm from, yams are called sweet potatoes, and potatoes are called "Western yams."
Jake:就就不叫土豆了
Jake: So they don't call them potatoes?
Lucia: 大家也知道土豆是什么
Lucia: But everyone knows what a potato is.
Lucia: 哦不不怎么叫哦
Lucia: Oh no, no, how do you call it?
Alice:我们那不用洋芋这个名
Alice: We don't use the name "yangyu."
Alice:所以你说洋芋可能就有的就不知道啥
Alice: So if you say "yangyu," some people might not know what it is.
Alice:我们就土豆
Alice: We just call it "tudou."
Lucia: 那你们洋葱叫什么
Lucia: Then what do you call onions?
Alice:洋葱
Alice: Onions.
Alice:啊粘哈哈哈
Alice: Ah, sticky hahaha.
Lucia: 就是啊啊呀
Lucia: Yeah, right?
Lucia: 比如说甘肃和陕西是吧
Lucia: Like in Gansu and Shaanxi, right?
Lucia: 甘肃和新疆那边叫皮牙子
Lucia: In Gansu and Xinjiang, they call it "piyazi."
Lucia: 皮牙子
Lucia: Piyazi.
Jake:皮牙子
Jake: Piyazi.
Lucia: 我也不知道为什么这么叫
Lucia: I don't know why they call it that.
Lucia: 听着有点喜感
Lucia: It sounds kind of funny.
Lucia: 但是总之就是那边会这么叫
Lucia: But anyway, that's what they call it there.
Tasha: 我想起来皮燕子
Tasha: It reminds me of "piyanzi."
Alice:还有什么
Alice: What else?
Jake:哈哈哈体验的是什么啊
Jake: Hahaha, what are you experiencing?
Alice:啊哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Ahahahahahaha.
Lucia: 这个要给他解释吗
Lucia: Should we explain this to him?
Tasha: 哈哈哈不要了
Tasha: Hahaha, no need.
Jake:好对不起
Jake: Okay, sorry.
Lucia: 你多上中文互联网冲一下
Lucia: You should spend more time on the Chinese internet.
Tasha: 不好不好意思我不是在故意的
Tasha: Sorry, sorry, I didn't do it on purpose.
Tasha: 吃饭的时候
Tasha: While eating.
Tasha: 吃饭的时候说这个
Tasha: Talking about this while eating.
Tasha: 反正他也没听懂
Tasha: Anyway, he didn't get it.
Tasha: 呵呵
Tasha: Hehe.
Tasha: 是吗
Tasha: Right?
Jake:可能是吧
Jake: Maybe.
Jake:回头冲冲浪
Jake: I'll surf later.
Alice:杨老板昨天的照片太显年轻了
Alice: Jake's photo from yesterday makes him look really young.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Tasha: GPT里
Tasha: On GPT.
Jake:嗯就是
Jake: Yeah, that's it.
Jake:头像头像
Jake: Avatar, avatar.
Tasha: 这这爱好不小众
Tasha: This hobby isn't very niche.
Tasha: 我也喜欢
Tasha: I like it too.
Shure: 24号就是后天了
Shure: The 24th is the day after tomorrow.
Shure: 放弃了
Shure: I gave up.
Shure: 但是有购买记录了
Shure: But there's a purchase record.
Shure: 就是他他死无对证这个事情
Shure: So he can't deny it.
Shure: 因为他到期那个资源就给给我释放了
Shure: Because when it expired, the resources were released to me.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Shure: 对所以我说我训过
Shure: Yeah, so I said I trained.
Shure: 他又不知道我训没训过是吧
Shure: He doesn't know if I trained or not, right?
Jake:确实
Jake: True.
Lucia: 而且我今天是周二嘛
Lucia: And today is Tuesday.
Alice:刚想回去喝点水
Alice: I was just about to go have some water.
Alice:洋葱
Alice: Onion.
Shure: 我之前会去他们APP
Shure: I used to go on their app.
Shure: 上看就比如我去
Shure: And look, for example, when I...
Shure: 他没说什么时候
Shure: He didn't say when.
Alice:下午几点录房间呢
Alice: What time are we recording the room this afternoon?
Jake:现在吧
Jake: Now, I guess.
Alice:现在收拾一下吧
Alice: Let's clean up now then.
Jake:就是
Jake: Exactly.
Jake:尽快吧
Jake: As soon as possible.
Alice:尽快
Alice: As soon as possible.
Jake:吃完吃完收拾收拾
Jake: Let's clean up after eating.
Jake:我开始扫
Jake: I'll start sweeping.
Jake:你们在外面待着
Jake: You guys stay outside.
Alice:那我去收拾一下
Alice: Then I'll go tidy up.
Jake:或者在4月30
Jake: Or maybe on April 30th.
Lucia: 还要再扫一遍
Lucia: We need to sweep again.
Jake:不要扫
Jake: No need to sweep.
Jake:扫一遍你们装饰之后的就长不一样了
Jake: If we sweep after you decorate, it'll look different.
Jake:呵呵呵是吧
Jake: Haha, right?
Lucia: 有一些有一些
Lucia: A bit, a bit.
Lucia: 美容值掉下来了
Lucia: The aesthetic value dropped.
Lucia: 我再回去粘一下
Lucia: I'll go stick it again.
Jake:好嘞那我先扫你的
Jake: Okay, I'll sweep your place first.
Jake:先扫你的屋子哦
Jake: I'll sweep your room first.
Lucia: 你说我粘好之后哦
Lucia: You mean after I stick it?
Tasha: 现在就是扫装饰完的是吗
Tasha: Now we sweep after decorating, right?
Jake:嗯嗯嗯
Jake: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Alice:我的也快扫吧
Alice: Sweep mine too.
Alice:因为我那个胶
Alice: Because my glue...
Jake:好好
Jake: Okay, okay.
Lucia: 哦对
Lucia: Oh, right.
Alice:它老掉对对
Alice: It keeps falling off, right.
Lucia:  我今天早上起来发现他又掉了
Lucia: This morning I woke up and found it fell off again.
Lucia: 那我以为不用了
Lucia: So I thought we didn't need it anymore.
Lucia: 我就没粘
Lucia: I didn't stick it.
Alice:对
Alice: Yeah.
Lucia: 我想在上面粘一下然后再粘
Lucia: I was thinking of sticking it first and then sticking it again.
Alice:啊我全都在
Alice: Ah, I have all of them.
Jake:那我先扫二楼
Jake: Then I'll sweep the second floor first.
Jake:我先扫你的屋子
Jake: I'll sweep your room first.
Jake:然后你的屋子
Jake: Then your room.
Jake: And then your room.
Jake:二楼就
Jake: So the second floor...
Jake:我在二楼的时候你们就在一楼待着
Jake: When I'm on the second floor, you guys stay on the first floor.
Jake:然后你可以在一楼再贴一贴
Jake: Then you can stick it on the first floor.
Jake:我下来的时候你就上去
Jake: When I come down, you go up.
Alice:OK
Alice: OK.
Alice:可以在院子里面也行
Alice: You can also do it in the yard.
Jake:就这么回事
Jake: That's the plan.
Alice:怎么呢
Alice: What's up?
Jake:哼哼你倒一点
Jake: Hmph, pour a little.
Lucia: 你给我倒点
Lucia: Pour some for me.
Lucia: 我给你拿点别的
Lucia: I'll get you something else.
Lucia: 哈哈应该还有别的吗
Lucia: Haha, there should be something else, right?
Alice:咋回事是咋回事
Alice: What's going on? What's going on?
Shure: 哦特别喜欢特别喜欢
Shure: Oh, I really like it, really like it.
Jake:哦到位了
Jake: Oh, it's spot on.
Jake:挺好走一遍流程
Jake: Great, let's go through the process.
Lucia: 我去看看还有啥喝的给你拿一点
Lucia: I'll see what else we have to drink and get you some.
Jake:哼哼找找
Jake: Hmph, look around.
Jake:喝
Jake: Drink.
Jake:喝吗
Jake: Drink?
Jake:喝水里面有可乐喝
Jake: Drink, there's cola in the water.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Shure: 可乐好像也没了
Shure: Seems like the cola is also gone.
Jake:好嘞
Jake: Got it.
Jake:哈哈哈发生什么事了
Jake: Haha, what happened?
Lucia: 差点把这玉米油给打了
Lucia: Almost spilled this corn oil.
Jake:哈哈我靠
Jake: Haha, oh my.
Jake:哈哈哈谢谢谢
Jake: Haha, thanks a lot.
Jake:谢应该挺好喝
Jake: Thanks, it should be pretty good.
Tasha: noting
Tasha: Noting
Tasha: 楼上有
Tasha: There's some upstairs
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Alice:这你东西吗
Alice: Is this your stuff?
Jake:搅拌搅拌
Jake: Stir it
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha
Jake:威士忌油
Jake: Whiskey oil
Jake:搅拌搅拌
Jake: Stir it
Alice:算了这个就搁这
Alice: Forget it, just leave it here
Shure: 你也着急吗
Shure: Are you in a hurry too?
Lucia: 笑死我了楼上应该还有什么喝的
Lucia: That made me laugh, there should be something to drink upstairs
Tasha: 可口可乐
Tasha: Coca-Cola
Alice:还有啥没融进去的
Alice: Is there anything that hasn't melted yet?
Alice:差不多了
Alice: Almost done
Tasha: 我不喝好
Tasha: I don't want to drink anymore, okay?
Tasha: 有点有点喝不下了
Tasha: I'm a bit too full to drink more
Tasha: 饱了
Tasha: Full
Jake:饿扁了喝不下了
Jake: Starving but can't drink more
Lucia: 我们还有这个今天应该不用了吧
Lucia: We still have this, we probably won't need it today, right?
Jake:哎这个好
Jake: Oh, this is good
Jake:这个可以喝呵呵
Jake: This one can be drunk, hehe
Lucia: 这应该也还有
Lucia: There should be more of this too
Jake:这个可以喝
Jake: This one can be drunk
Lucia: 其他的好像没啥了
Lucia: Seems like there's nothing else
Jake:好够了喝
Jake: Okay, enough to drink
Jake:足够
Jake: Enough
Jake:足够喝一壶
Jake: Enough to drink a pot
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm
Lucia: 我的灯还亮着吗
Lucia: Is my light still on?
Jake:不亮了
Jake: It's off
Lucia: 我刚突然反应过来
Lucia: I just realized it
Lucia: 我好像我把线拿了下来
Lucia: I think I unplugged the cable
Lucia: 但是没有接上
Lucia: But didn't plug it back in
Jake:哦充电宝那边有很多哦
Jake: Oh, there are many power banks over there
Lucia: 没事充电宝在这哦
Lucia: No worries, the power bank is here
Lucia: 处理的任务太多了
Lucia: Too many tasks to handle
Jake:哈哈哈你的任务太多了
Lucia: 我现在把这个关了
Lucia: I'll turn this off now
Jake:好的
Jake: Okay
Jake:先倒点桃汁
Jake: Pour some peach juice first.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Jake:请能来个新的吧
Jake: Could we get a new one, please?
Jake:咱不差杯子
Jake: We're not short of cups.
Lucia: 我先把这个看下
Lucia: Let me check this first.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Jake:喝吗
Jake: Want a drink?
Jake:他他好像都没有喝
Jake: It seems like he hasn't drunk any.
Jake:你喝吗这些东西
Jake: Do you drink these things?
Jake:好的
Jake: Okay.
Shure: 因为我来北京什么的
Shure: Because when I came to Beijing...
Jake:喝吗
Jake: Want a drink?
Alice:我手机在这吗
Alice: Is my phone here?
Shure: 他这个能查到多多少啊
Shure: How much can this check?
Lucia: 好像没有啊
Lucia: Seems like it isn't.
Jake:没看着
Jake: Didn't see it.
Shure: 我到不了
Shure: I can't reach it.
Shure: 我前面肯定更有啊
Shure: There must be more ahead.
Shure: 去解锁哎呀
Shure: Go unlock it, oh man.
Shure: 还要会员
Shure: Need a membership.
Shure: 我去你不用
Shure: Come on, you don't need it.
其他人：不用啊
Others: No need.
Jake:会员
Jake: Membership.
其他人：我历史上都没有啊
Others: I never had it before.
Shure: 那可能从那时候就开始有了
Shure: Maybe it started from that time.
其他人：乱飞在这里
Others: Flying around here.
其他人：乱飞
Others: Flying around.
其他人：非常最多
Others: The most frequent.
Jake:你们一半的饭
Jake: You guys eat only half.
Jake:只吃一半
Jake: Just half.
Jake:一半的一半是吧
Jake: Half of half, right?
Jake:嗯这你就是健胃超市便
Jake: Yeah, that's why you need digestive tablets.
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Right.
Shure: 我们两个都吃完了
Shure: Both of us finished our meal.
Jake:加上了两个健胃消食片
Jake: Added two digestive tablets.
Shure: 对我还
Shure: Yeah, I even...
Shure: 我还加餐两个健胃消食片呢
Shure: I even had two more digestive tablets.
Jake:对嗯
Jake: Yeah, hmm.
其他人：你看18 对在上高中
Others: Look, 18, yeah, still in high school.
其他人：完全没有出门
Others: Never went out.
Jake:这啥呀这是
Jake: What's this?
Lucia: 洋葱
Lucia: Onion.
Jake:炒洋葱是吧
Jake: Stir-fried onions, right?
Jake:嗯这道菜
Jake: Hmm, this dish...
Lucia: 然后还有回锅肉
Lucia: And also twice-cooked pork.
Jake:回锅肉没有找到了
Jake: We couldn't find the twice-cooked pork.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Katrina: 嗨
Katrina: Hi.
Katrina: 你在哪呢
Katrina: Where are you?
Katrina: 你搁哪呢
Katrina: 在新家
Katrina: At the new house.
Katrina: 你看昨天给你拍照片我就说话不利索
Katrina: You know, yesterday when I took the photo for you, I was fumbling with words.
Katrina: 呵呵我说昨天给你发的照片看了不
Katrina: Haha, did you see the photo I sent you yesterday?
Katrina: 还好我没发吗
Katrina: Good thing I didn't send it, right?
Katrina: 他们装扮的都好好看
Katrina: They all look really nice.
Katrina: 我以后也要搞成这个样子
Katrina: I want to dress like that too in the future.
Katrina: 我明天早上把我买的一些东西寄回去
Katrina: I'll send back some stuff I bought tomorrow morning.
Katrina: 啊上次买的那衣服寄到家了吗
Katrina: Oh, did the clothes I bought last time arrive at home?
Katrina: 哦上次
Katrina: Oh, last time...
Katrina: 你知道那两大坨寄快递好多钱吗
Katrina: Do you know how much it cost to ship those two big packages?
Katrina: 对啊我跟你说过了
Katrina: Yeah, I told you.
Katrina: 原来超便宜
Katrina: It was super cheap.
Katrina: 今天22号啊
Katrina: Today is the 22nd, right?
Katrina: 今天休息一天
Katrina: Taking a day off today.
Jake:今天你们不在干活吗
Jake: Aren't you guys working today?
Katrina: 我
Katrina: I...
Jake:现在你妈妈也在干活
Jake: Even your mom is working now.
Jake:但是没有 工资呵呵
Lucia: 我觉得只要出境的人都在干活
Lucia: I think everyone who's on screen is working.
Katrina: 啊
Katrina: Ah.
Jake:嗯确实确实
Jake: Yeah, definitely.
Katrina: 我爹在装空调
Katrina: My dad's installing the air conditioner.
Lucia: 全民大工作呵呵
Lucia: It's like a national work campaign, haha.
Lucia: 那个大学习全身是什么
Lucia: What's that "big learning" thing?
Jake:呵呵我赵青有所耳闻
Jake: Haha, I've heard a bit about it.
Jake:Lucia:
Jake: Lucia...
Katrina: 这个卡其色是什么东西
Katrina: What's this khaki thing?
Lucia: 那个什么大学习
Lucia: That "big learning" thing...
Lucia: 是全民大学习吗
Lucia: Is it the national big learning?
Lucia: 青年大学习
Lucia: Youth big learning program.
Jake:青年青年
Lucia: 因为我们学校好像没有那个
Lucia: Because it seems like our school doesn't have that.
Jake:没有哪个
Jake: Doesn't have what?
Lucia: 没有那个
Lucia: Doesn't have that.
Katrina: 看不清呀
Katrina: Can't see clearly.
Jake:亲现在哦
Jake: Dear, now oh.
Katrina: 这啥颜色呀
Katrina: What color is this?
Lucia: OK但是其实我上学那会
Lucia: OK, but actually when I was in school...
Lucia: 就是我认识的别的学校同学都有的
Lucia: The students I knew from other schools all had it.
Katrina: 行啊都行啊
Katrina: Sure, it's all good.
Lucia: 就是已经有了
Lucia: They already had it.
Katrina: 现在我已经会装饰我的房间了
Katrina: Now I can already decorate my room.
Lucia: 以现就不太熟
Lucia: I'm not too familiar with it now.
Jake:没怎么学过
Jake: Haven't really studied it.
Jake:有点落伍我就没
Jake: A bit outdated, I just haven't.
Lucia:  我为什么会觉得他叫全民大学习呢
Lucia: Why do I feel like it's called "National Learning"?
Katrina: 可以啊
Katrina: Yeah, sure.
Jake:确实结论上是全民大学习
Jake: Indeed, the conclusion is "National Learning".
Katrina: 可以啊你搞绿色就行
Katrina: Sure, you just do green.
Katrina: 反正我现在买东西都是绿色系
Katrina: Anyway, everything I buy now is green.
Katrina: 好的OK没问题
Katrina: Alright, OK, no problem.
Lucia: 我们虽然没有那个青年大学习
Lucia: Although we don't have that "Youth Learning" thing.
Lucia: 但我们有语课堂
Lucia: But we have "Language Classroom".
Jake:语课堂就类似的东西
Jake: "Language Classroom" is a similar thing.
Katrina: 收拾收拾房间
Katrina: Cleaning up the room.
Katrina: 洗洗碗睡睡觉
Katrina: Washing dishes, sleeping.
Lucia: 就是怎么形容它有点像Cosera
Lucia: It's kind of like Coursera.
Jake:OK
Jake: OK.
Jake:上面刻是什么呀
Jake: What's engraved on it?
Katrina: 是要收拾收拾东西
Katrina: Need to tidy up some stuff.
Lucia: 就是学校老师会把那些课件
Lucia: The school teachers upload their courseware there.
Lucia: 之类的传到上面
Lucia: And things like that.
Jake:OK OK
Jake: OK, OK.
Lucia:  然后就是需要在那上面看那个课件啊
Lucia: Then you need to watch the courseware on it.
Katrina: 是啊回去写毕社了都
Katrina: Yeah, go home and write the thesis.
Katrina: 不习惯了都
Katrina: Not used to it anymore.
Lucia: 然后我每次看完也像科32一样
Lucia: And every time after watching, it's like Coursera.
Lucia: 他还有那种选择题
Lucia: It also has multiple-choice questions.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Lucia: 嗯但是鉴于我
Lucia: Hmm, but given that I...
Katrina: 毕业还是没问题的
Katrina: Graduating shouldn't be a problem.
Lucia: 鉴于我平时不怎么看视频
Lucia: Considering I don't usually watch videos.
Katrina: 能别这么呵呵
Katrina: Can you stop being so sarcastic?
Lucia: ：Tasha:
Lucia: Tasha:
Tasha:  哈哈现在有PPT了就好多了
Tasha: Haha, now that we have PPTs, it's much better.
Jake:在有GPT了就好多了
Jake: Now that we have GPT, it's much better.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Lucia: 我们在这生物
Lucia: We are in biology.
Lucia: 生物学原理
Lucia: Principles of biology.
Lucia: 还是生物学原理
Lucia: Still principles of biology.
Jake:哈哈哈就学这些东西
Jake: Hahaha, we just study these things.
Lucia: 对我们还学这个
Lucia: Yeah, we still study this.
Lucia: 没想到
Lucia: Didn't expect it.
Jake:没想到
Jake: Didn't expect it.
Katrina: 我爹吗
Katrina: My dad, huh?
Lucia: 然后这个课也有
Lucia: And this course too.
Lucia: 那个语课堂都不会
Lucia: Even the language class doesn't cover it.
Jake:好吧
Jake: Alright then.
Katrina: 哈哈
Katrina: Haha.
Katrina: 哈我爹这头好搞笑
Katrina: Haha, my dad is so funny.
Jake:我们北游的课比较离谱的
Jake: Our courses at Beiyou are quite ridiculous.
Jake:就是所有的学科都要学
Jake: We have to study all subjects.
Jake:学傅里叶变换
Jake: Study Fourier transforms.
Jake:傅里叶变换就学日语学
Jake: Fourier transforms in Japanese.
Jake:学俄语也要学复利页变换
Jake: Even Russian requires Fourier transforms.
Lucia: 为什么呀
Lucia: Why?
Lucia: 用不到啊
Lucia: It's not useful.
Jake:就是嘿嘿
Jake: Just, hehe.
Jake:可能翻译著作吧
Jake: Maybe for translating works.
Lucia: 翻译
Lucia: Translating?
Lucia: 翻译数学著作吗
Lucia: Translating math works?
Jake:呃同性原理
Jake: Uh, same principles.
Jake:同性的东西
Jake: Same stuff.
Lucia: 统计学呀
Lucia: Statistics?
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Lucia: 我学盖桶的时候学的不太好
Lucia: When I was learning Gaitong, I didn't do well.
Lucia: 但是学那个ignometrics
Lucia: But when learning that ignometrics.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Lucia: 中文叫什么
Lucia: What's it called in Chinese?
Lucia: 计量经济学
Lucia: Econometrics.
Jake:的时候
Jake: When
Jake:嗯
Lucia: 你看我其实英文没有变好
Lucia: You see, my English hasn't actually improved
Lucia: 但是中文变差了
Lucia: But my Chinese has gotten worse
Jake:我今天哈哈哈哈
Jake: Today I... hahaha
Jake:没英文英文变好了
Jake: No, your English has improved
Jake:英文好了
Jake: Your English is better
Lucia: 速度完全赶不上我的同学
Lucia: My speed can't keep up with my classmates
Jake:哈哈哈没关系
Jake: Hahaha, it's okay
Jake:混着说
Jake: Just mix it up
Lucia: 然后学那个计量的时候
Lucia: And when I was learning metrics
Lucia: 因为很多东西概统学过一次
Lucia: Because I had already studied many things in statistics once
Lucia: 嗯然后于是就突然学了很多
Lucia: Hmm, and then suddenly learned a lot more
Katrina: 咱还有水果吃吗
Katrina: Do we still have any fruit?
Jake:有水果汁
Jake: We have fruit juice
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahaha
Jake:这什么水果
Jake: What kind of fruit is this?
Jake:双鸭三鸭这是
Jake: Two ducks, three ducks, what is this?
Jake:哈哈哈哎呀
Jake: Haha, oh my
Lucia: AI能反应过来吗
Lucia: Can AI understand this?
Jake:确实没有水果吃
Jake: Indeed, there's no fruit to eat
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Alice:怎么啦
Alice: What's up?
Lucia: 这要说话带口音的话怎么办呀
Lucia: What to do if you speak with an accent?
Lucia: 只和吃的好
Lucia: Just eat well
Jake:嗯哼哼差别不大
Jake: Hmm, the difference isn't big
其他人： 哎呀我真烦你们
Others: Oh my, you guys are so annoying
Shure: 那你去呗
Shure: Then go ahead
Shure: 我又不是没让你
Shure: I didn't stop you
Shure: 那你买不就不用我买了吗
Shure: If you buy it, I don't have to
Lucia: 我小时候我妈给我讲过一个笑话是嗯
Lucia: When I was young, my mom told me a joke
Katrina: 好看好看
Katrina: Looks good, looks good
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm
Lucia: 就陕西话里面就是头
Lucia: In Shaanxi dialect, the word for head
Katrina: 好看很高级
Katrina: Looks very high-end
Shure: 这生什么气啊
Shure: Why are you so angry?
Jake:嗯就是
Jake: Hmm, it's like
Lucia: 如果是很很很传统的方言是头这个词
Lucia: If it's a very traditional dialect, the word for head is...
Shure: 买对的就行
Shure: Just buy the right one
Katrina: 好看自己开心就好
Katrina: Looks good, as long as you're happy
Shure: 给我妹求成姻缘就行
Shure: Just ask for a good match for my sister.
Lucia: 这叫啥
Lucia: What's this called?
Jake:嗯
Katrina: 你自己的钱
Katrina: Your own money.
Jake:啥对
Jake: What, right?
Jake:这是啥对这是
Jake: What is this, really?
Lucia: 这是啥这是
Lucia: What is this?
Jake:哈哈哈哈他确实不知道这是啥对吧
Jake: Hahaha, he really doesn't know what this is, does he?
Jake:为为为什么
Jake: Why, why?
Lucia: 摇头脑对吧
Lucia: Shake your head, right?
Jake:嗯对啊
Jake: Yeah, right.
Lucia: 不知道为啥
Jake:他为什么叫撒
Jake: Why is it called that?
Lucia: 不知道
Lucia: Don't know.
Jake:一般会怎么用呢
Jake: How is it usually used?
Jake:就是我我撒上有个撒
Jake: Like, I have something on me.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Lucia: 所以有一个笑话
Lucia: So there's a joke.
Lucia: 就是有一个陕西人走进医院
Lucia: There's this guy from Shaanxi who walks into a hospital.
Lucia: 对医生说医生
Lucia: And he says to the doctor, "Doctor,
Lucia: 我撒疼
Lucia: I have pain."
Lucia:   然后医生说你撒疼我怎么能知道呢
Lucia: Then the doctor says, "How am I supposed to know where it hurts?"
Jake:好吧
Jake: Alright.
Jake:哼你爱咋疼咋疼
Jake: Hmph, hurt wherever you want.
Lucia: 但其实现在我觉得
Lucia: But actually, I think nowadays
Lucia: 就是即使老一辈的基本上也都说疼OK
Lucia: even the older generation just says "pain" okay?
Jake:OK实在不好用这个词对不
Jake: Okay, it's really not good to use this word, right?
Lucia: 是不是很好用
Lucia: Isn't it useful?
Jake:对哈哈哈
Jake: Yeah, hahaha.
Lucia: 虽然我们家就是不
Lucia: Although in my family, we don't
Lucia: 就是平常都说普通话
Lucia: we usually speak Mandarin.
Lucia: 但是我觉得我感觉啊
Lucia: But I feel like, you know
Katrina: 就是你放在这个
Katrina: It's just that if you put it in this
Katrina: 不放在特定的语音里的话
Katrina: Without specific context
Lucia: 就即使你是陕西有时候也反应不过来
Lucia: Even if you're from Shaanxi, you might not get it.
Jake:哦是我会这么觉得啊
Jake: Oh, that's how I feel too.
Lucia: 我会这么觉得啊
Lucia: That's how I feel too.
Jake:当然可能人家如果
Jake: Of course, maybe if someone
Jake:就是一直语言环境都这样啥
Jake: is always in that language environment
Jake:应该是东北东北话
Jake: it should be Northeastern dialect.
Jake:然后以前陕西那边没什么东北人
Jake: Back then, there weren't many Northeastern people in Shaanxi.
Jake:就还没还好
Jake: So it was okay.
Jake:哈哈是吧东北就是不去陕西
Jake: Haha, right? People from the Northeast wouldn't go to Shaanxi.
Shure: 东北人又怎么了
Shure: What's wrong with Northeastern people?
Jake:因为陕西里边他们把头叫啥
Jake: Because in Shaanxi, what do they call the head?
Lucia: 啥就是最最最传统陕西方言的话
Lucia: It's the most traditional Shaanxi dialect.
其他人：好看呢好看呢
Others: Looks good, looks good.
Jake:就是因为这个
Jake: It's because of that.
Lucia: 就是这是啥
Lucia: So what is this?
Jake:就是这是啥
Jake: So what is this?
Jake:但是因为因为以前陕西东北人对
Jake: But because, because before, in Shaanxi Northeastern people...
Jake:这是啥
Jake: What is this?
Lucia: 应该是这样
Lucia: It should be like this.
Lucia: 我妈给我讲的我可以再找他合作
Lucia: My mom told me, I can work with him again.
Katrina: 看家里有味道吗
Katrina: Is there a smell in the house?
Lucia: 但好像确实是这样
Lucia: But it seems to be true.
Lucia: 因为我听完之后我去
Lucia: Because after hearing it, I went to...
Lucia:  问了我姥
Lucia: Ask my grandma.
Katrina: 不是要通风3个月吗
Katrina: Didn't you need to ventilate for 3 months?
Lucia: 婆但是其实就是现在
Lucia: But actually now...
Lucia: ：反正基本上都不能
Lucia: Basically, you can't...
Katrina: 你买个测甲醛测一下
Katrina: You should buy a formaldehyde detector and test it.
Jake:那陕西的就是陕西自己也有啥是吗
Jake: So Shaanxi people also have their own way of saying "what," right?
Jake:这个还是没有
Jake: This one still doesn't.
Katrina: 那你每天都通风吗
Katrina: Do you ventilate every day?
Jake:他们管你叫什么吗
Jake: What do they call you?
Lucia: 有吧我觉得有
Lucia: I think they do.
Jake:有啥哦
Jake: They do, oh.
Lucia: 只不过跟普通话这个啥
Lucia: But it's different from the standard Mandarin "what."
Jake:OK
Jake:可能音也不是完全一样
Jake: Maybe the proShure's GFciation isn't exactly the same.
Jake:OK
Jake: OK.
Lucia: 有有可以啊
Lucia: Yes, it works.
Lucia: 比如说没听清你说什么就就会说13
Lucia: For example, if they didn't hear what you said, they would say "13."
Jake:哦那就是有
Jake: Oh, so there is.
Jake:哈哈很地道
Jake: Haha, very authentic.
Jake:很地道了
Jake: Very authentic.
Katrina: 看我们在外面吃饭
Katrina: Look, we're eating out.
Lucia: 所以我们还有水果吃吗嗯
Lucia: So do we still have fruit to eat? Hmm.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Katrina: 每天穿个睡衣垫个拖鞋
Katrina: Every day I wear pajamas and slippers.
Lucia: 楼上好像还有一个山竹
Lucia: There's still a mangosteen upstairs.
Jake:哦可以
Jake: Oh, okay.
Jake:山竹可能能发个分个8本
Jake: The mangosteen can probably be split into 8 pieces.
Lucia: 一人一瓣
Lucia: One piece each.
Katrina: 对啊然后昨天邀请杜卓芸他们来玩
Katrina: Yeah, and yesterday I invited Du Zhuoyun and them to hang out.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Jake:吃完再拿
Jake: Finish eating first.
Katrina: 上次我也没来
Katrina: I didn't come last time either.
Jake:把这两个蛋给吃完了
Jake: Finish these two eggs first.
Katrina: 上次我也有家教
Katrina: I had tutoring last time too.
Katrina: 本来每个人就是邀请一到两个
Katrina: Originally, each person was supposed to invite one or two.
Lucia: 领导你不用这么努力
Lucia: Boss, you don't have to work so hard.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Katrina: 邀请多了
Katrina: Invited too many.
Katrina: 那就我们都准备
Katrina: So we all had to prepare.
Katrina: 不准备不够啊
Katrina: If we didn't prepare, it wouldn't be enough.
Lucia: 我都不好意思了
Lucia: I felt so embarrassed.
Katrina: 他们要做甜点呀什么的
Katrina: They wanted to make desserts and stuff.
Jake:哈哈哈挺挺好吃挺好吃
Jake: Haha, it's pretty delicious.
Katrina: 开地铁来了两个小时
Katrina: Took two hours by subway.
Jake:他从哪来的
Jake: Where did he come from?
Katrina: 北京就是这样啊
Katrina: That's how it is in Beijing.
Katrina: 通勤时间很长
Katrina: Commute time is very long.
Jake:他是从清华来的哦
Jake: He came from Tsinghua, oh.
Katrina: 他从清华来五道口
Katrina: He came from Tsinghua to Wudaokou.
Katrina: 什么叫浪费别人的时间
Katrina: What do you mean wasting other people's time?
Katrina: 这个是一起过来玩
Katrina: This is just hanging out together.
Katrina:    刘凯琳也在家教啊
Katrina: Liu Kailin is also tutoring.
Katrina:    还没有   熟呢
Katrina: Liu Kailin isn't as familiar as Du Zhuoyun.
Katrina:    还没有   熟啊
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Hmm.
Katrina: 大学聊的不是那么多
Katrina: Didn't chat much in college.
Katrina: 而且人家有女朋友
Katrina: And he has a girlfriend.
Jake:控制他我今天早上修硕他们俩
Jake: Control him, this morning Shure and them...
Jake:他们俩今天把这个收拾完了
Jake: They finished cleaning this up today.
Jake:然后我早上一看
Jake: Then I looked in the morning,
Jake:我靠我看这桌子
Jake: Damn, I saw this table.
Jake:这桌子空了
Jake: The table was empty.
Jake:吓我一跳
Jake: Scared me.
Jake:我以为风先吹走了
Jake: I thought the wind blew it away first.
Jake:呵呵没事咱就给他
Jake: Haha, it's fine, we'll just give it to him.
Katrina: 每天都玩到12点
Katrina: Play until midnight every day.
Katrina: 对啊今天早上睡到11点半
Katrina: Yeah, slept until 11:30 this morning.
Jake:对
Jake: Right.
Jake:谢谢哎
Jake: Thanks.
Lucia: 哎呀对不起
Lucia: Oh, sorry.
Jake:没事
Jake: It's okay.
Katrina: 嘿嘿
Katrina: Hehe.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Katrina: 又不喊我
Katrina: Didn't call me again.
Katrina: 起床很爽
Katrina: It feels great to wake up.
Shure: 好困呀
Shure: So sleepy.
Lucia: 这个没气
Lucia: This one's out of air.
Lucia: 给你倒满点
Lucia: Let me refill it for you.
Jake:呵呵呵
Jake: Hehehe.
Katrina: 又开始了
Katrina: Starting again.
Jake:谢谢
Jake: Thanks.
Katrina: 你拿我当你的镜子呢
Katrina: Are you using me as your mirror?
Jake:嗯没关系
Jake: Hmm, it's okay.
Katrina: 好看啊感觉你的胶原蛋白比我还多
Katrina: You look good, feels like you have more collagen than me.
Jake:还有多少好
Jake: How much more good stuff is there?
Jake:好吧好吧好吧
Jake: Alright, alright, alright.
Katrina: 我明天下午要去一趟雍和宫
Katrina: I'm going to Yonghe Temple tomorrow afternoon.
Katrina: 我要去还愿去
Katrina: I need to fulfill my vow.
Katrina: 还愿啊你当时求的东西准了
Katrina: Fulfill the vow, the thing you prayed for came true.
Katrina: 你不得去还个愿吗
Katrina: You gotta go fulfill the vow, right?
Katrina: 我自己去还愿
Katrina: I'll go fulfill the vow myself.
Jake:还愿多少钱
Jake: How much to fulfill a vow?
Katrina: 不要钱去那磕个头
Katrina: It's free, just go there and bow.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Katrina: 雍和宫不要门票吧
Katrina: Yonghe Temple doesn't need an entrance fee, right?
Katrina: 哦好像要门票 5块钱
Katrina: Oh, seems like there's a ticket, 5 yuan.
Jake:那烧香多少钱
Jake: How much for the incense?
Katrina: 烧香是
Katrina: Incense is...
Katrina: 烧香是带的
Katrina: Incense is brought by you.
Katrina: 门票是带的
Katrina: Ticket includes it.
Katrina: 明天晚上就住北郊附近
Katrina: Tomorrow night, I'll stay near the northern suburbs.
Katrina: 又跟上紫薇林
Katrina: Hanging out with Violet again.
Katrina: 他哪天没时间
Katrina: Which day is he free?
Katrina: 就在他们学校旁边
Katrina: It's right next to their school.
Katrina: 他只是从宿舍走出来而已
Katrina: He just walked out of the dorm.
Katrina: 哇这是什么年轻小伙子呀
Katrina: Wow, what a young guy!
Katrina: 像那种30岁的企业
Katrina: Like a 30-year-old enterprise.
Katrina: 我爸我爸是奶油小生哈
Katrina: My dad, my dad is a handsome guy.
Katrina: 哈
Katrina: Ha.
Katrina: 麻将我就
Katrina: Mahjong, I just...
Jake:哼哼
Jake: Hmph hmph.
Katrina: 这个叫什么
Katrina: What's this called?
Katrina: 这个叫爱好
Katrina: This is called a hobby.
Katrina: 能使人永葆年轻
Katrina: It can keep people young forever.
Lucia: 我今天怎么变成了
Lucia: How did I become like this today?
Lucia:  不太对吧
Lucia: It's not right, is it?
Tasha: 他这是L3
Tasha: He's L3.
Tasha: 现在他叫
Tasha: Now he's called...
Jake:哦对要改一下
Jake: Oh right, gotta change it.
Jake:这就是你的了
Jake: This is yours now.
Lucia: 谢谢嗯
Lucia: Thanks, yeah.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Yeah.
Jake:缩改
Jake: Shorten it.
Jake:你刚刚是帮人欢了吗
Jake: Were you just helping someone cheer up?
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Jake:我我看看去
Jake: Let me take a look.
Jake:哈哈我看看也要删
Jake: Haha, I need to delete it too.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Alice:我觉这屋大概是用不上了
Alice: I think this room probably won't be used anymore.
Alice:那就这样吧好
Alice: So, let's leave it like this, okay?
Jake:你好
Jake: Hello.
Jake:关了你关掉了
Jake: You turned it off, you turned it off.
Jake:你你现在关掉了对吧没关系
Jake: You, you turned it off now, right? It's okay.
Tasha: 一个人没有没有舍弃
Tasha: No one has abandoned anyone.
Jake:好吧
Jake: Okay.
Jake:薛明忠也不来
Jake: Xue Mingzhong isn't coming either.
Tasha: 我知道他不能来
Tasha: I know he can't come.
Tasha: 跟我说过他起不来
Tasha: He told me he can't get up.
Jake:好吧那你没法让他破防了
Jake: Okay, then you can't break his defense.
Tasha: 我我让他保密了
Tasha: I, I told him to keep it a secret.
Jake:哦已经破防了是吧
Jake: Oh, he's already broken, right?
Tasha: 他说自己有手
Tasha: He said he has hands.
Tasha: 他说更热吗
Tasha: Did he say it’s hotter?
Jake:让他烧起来吧
Jake: Let him turn it up.
Lucia:  你要是刚才连的真是L3的话
Lucia: If you really connected to L3 just now,
Lucia: L3上应该会有一个我命名的哦
Lucia: There should be something I named on L3.
Jake:没有他关了
Jake: No, he turned it off.
Jake:所以应该是连不上了
Jake: So it probably won’t connect.
Lucia: 因为我刚发现
Lucia: Because I just found out
Lucia: 我这上面还是昨天的文件
Lucia: The files here are still from yesterday.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Lucia: 所以我上一个可能连在了L3上
Lucia: So the last one might have connected to L3.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Mm.
Lucia: 就是这个还是昨天的文件
Lucia: It’s just that these are still yesterday’s files.
Lucia: 嗯我前面上一个文件可能连在了L3上
Lucia: Hmm, my previous file might have connected to L3.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Mm.
Jake:OK OK
Jake: OK, OK.
Lucia: 对
Lucia: 所以他现在才才到了L4
Lucia: So now it’s just reached L4.
Lucia: 那我要把之前的删掉
Lucia: I need to delete the previous ones.
Jake:对对对你边录边删都可以
Jake: Yes, yes, you can delete them as you record.
Lucia: 笑死突然变成L3
Lucia: So funny, it suddenly switched to L3.
Jake:哼
Jake: Hmph.
Shure: 真是人啊你
Shure: You’re really something.
Jake:哎你这纹的啥呀
Jake: Hey, what’s that tattoo?
其他人：嗯呃呃呃
Others: Hmm, uh, uh, uh.
Shure: 我刚刚换裤子换一半没换完
Shure: I was halfway through changing my pants.
Shure: 他出来然后就叭把门敞
Shure: He came out and just left the door open.
Jake:呵呵呵呵呵呵
Jake: Hahaha.
Jake:戴眼镜的问题
Jake: It’s the glasses issue.
Jake:没有呵呵呵
Jake: No, hahaha.
Shure: 这边没有摄像头吧
Shure: There’s no camera here, right?
Jake:没有没有
Jake: No, no.
Jake:你说哪边
Jake: Which side do you mean?
Shure: 我说这这边
Shure: I mean this side.
Jake:有有有这么个方向
Jake: There is, in that direction.
Shure: 那没事
Shure: Then it’s fine.
Jake:没关系没关系
Jake: It’s okay, it’s okay.
Jake:这是你的重生之日吗
Jake: Is this your rebirth day?
其他人：是我姥姥去
Others: It’s my grandma’s passing.
Shure: 真不见外
Shure: You’re really not shy.
Shure: 怎么喜欢share一下
Shure: Why do you like to share so much?
Shure: 是吗哈
Shure: Really, huh?
Shure: 哈
Shure: Huh
Shure: 我怎么穿上跟流氓一样
Shure: Why do I look like a thug in this outfit?
其他人：我就说这件衣服跟你像
Others: I told you this outfit suits you.
其他人：特别像
Others: It really does.
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah
Jake:挺好看的嗯
Jake: It looks pretty good, yeah.
Shure: 行我穿上了
Shure: Alright, I'm wearing it.
Jake:有什么面啊
Jake: What noodles do we have?
Shure: 这个吗嗯gold
Shure: This one? Yeah, gold.
Jake:gold
Jake: Gold.
Alice:这谁眼镜啊
Alice: Whose glasses are these?
Alice:这谁的眼镜吗
Shure: 啊我的我的我的谢谢
Shure: Ah, mine, mine, mine, thanks.
Shure: 这小哨我拿着
Shure: I'll take this whistle.
Shure: 卧槽这这一身太大了
Shure: Damn, this outfit is too big.
Shure: 这
Shure: This...
Shure: 拿小扇
Shure: Take the small fan.
Shure: 哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha
Shure: 文胸武肚生道里
Shure: Scholar or warrior, living in the way.
Shure: 那我应该我是文还是武文吧
Shure: So should I be a scholar or a warrior? Scholar, right?
Shure: 太帅了真是
Shure: Too handsome, really.
Shure: 你们有要取的快递吗
Shure: Do you guys have any packages to pick up?
Jake:嗯嗯嗯群里面看看吧
Jake: Hmm, check in the group.
Jake:群里喊一声
Jake: Ask in the group.
Jake:你们有快递
Jake: Do you guys have packages?
Jake:取不去
Jake: Going to pick them up or not?
Jake:那你们
Jake: Then you guys...
Shure: 我要去买一张刮刮乐哈哈哈
Shure: I'm going to buy a scratch-off ticket, hahaha.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈行行行
Jake: Hahahahaha, alright, alright, alright.
Jake:建立一些莫名其妙的联系
Jake: Establish some random connections.
Shure: 对
Shure: Yeah.
Jake:好嘞
Jake: Got it.
Shure: 门要关吗
Shure: Should we close the door?
Jake:关呗
Jake: Close it.
Shure: 那好吧
Shure: Alright then.
Jake:咱不是没水果
Jake: Don't we not have any fruit?
Jake:咱不是没有水果吗
Jake:啊
Jake: Ah.
Jake:不吃了不吃
Jake: I'm done eating, I'm done.
Jake:哈哈不用了不用了
Jake: Haha, no need, no need.
Lucia: 柯欣和他的小伙伴
Lucia: Colin and his buddies
Lucia: 慷慨的分给了我两个
Lucia: Generously gave me two.
Lucia: 你要不要慷慨的
Lucia: Do you want to be generous too?
Jake:那我慷我怎么慷慨
Jake: How can I be generous?
Lucia: 哈哈哈你要不
Lucia: Hahaha, do you want to...
Jake:哈哈哈我还能如何
Jake: Hahaha, what else can I do?
Lucia: 慷慨的还是留给我
Lucia: Be generous and leave it to me.
Jake:好的慷慨了
Jake: Okay, I'll be generous.
Jake:那我吃一个
Jake: Then I'll have one.
Lucia: 你看我相当于分给你1/2的水果
Lucia: You see, I gave you half of my fruit.
Lucia: 我是不是特别慷慨
Lucia: Aren't I very generous?
Jake:嗯对谢谢各位慷慨
Jake: Yeah, thanks everyone for being generous.
Alice:老板我的生命危遇危险
Alice: Boss, my life is in danger.
Alice:对我的生命安全受到了威胁
Alice: Yes, my life is threatened.
Jake:好算了
Jake: Okay, forget it.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahahaha
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahaha
Alice:哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahaha
Alice:他要在地上翻一个瓜子皮就把我腰斩
Alice: If he flips a sunflower seed shell on the ground, it might cut me in half.
Jake:瓜子皮是吧哈哈哈哈
Jake: Sunflower seed shell, huh? Hahahaha
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Lucia: life danger is secured
Lucia: Life danger is secured.
Jake:哎
Jake: Sigh.
Jake:你要采集一些不能播的数据
Jake: You need to collect some data that can't be broadcast.
Lucia: 笑的我都噎住了
Lucia: I'm laughing so hard, I choked.
Alice:啊采集些不能播的数据
Alice: Ah, collect some data that can't be broadcast.
Jake:就是采没有没有
Jake: Just collect... no, no.